[Music]
laughs stop Lois I'm your uncle Jonathan
are you wearing a roll it's a kimono
here we are home sweet home
[Music]
you're Luis I presume how was your trip
this old hag is my neighbor I'm relieved
to see you didn't inherit your uncle's
freakishly oversized head my god did
that withered purple skeleton just speak
you'll see it's quite different here
have a look around you're perfectly safe
safe as long as it's fed do you know
what a warlock is Lois a boy which I
think they're a little more than boy
witness are you seeing that you're a
warlock
please teach me please please okay have
it your way I can give you the right
books teach you the right spells but
that last one for Saturday that's up to
you
I don't want the creepy little runt sink
I wanted lucky shot
you've told Lois everything well not
everything this house used to be owned
by another warlock
he's very wicked very powerful he left a
hidden clock in the walls we don't know
what it does except something horrible
three dongs
last time it was for what happens when
it gets down to one nothing good that's
for certain
we have to destroy the clock
so creepy you can't do this alone I can
help you you wanna see some real magic
I'll show you
shall we die he puppies
[Applause]
[Music]